there's one thing I have to address
because I know people are going to bring
it up in the Blu-ray special feature
unlocking the five Keys executive
producer Bailey Conway angit offers a
different account of Key's history her
father was the assistant Warden of the
prison keyface was a very old prisoner
who was wronged and that's why he haunts
this property this isn't part of the
movie itself so I don't really consider
it Canon and there are several problems
with this statement she says keyface was
an old prisoner who is wrong there's no
evidence of that in the movie and he
specifically referred to as a demon
multiple times we know that demon are
non-human entities if you saw my man who
can't breathe video you may remember
that there was a similar mixup regarding
that character and Bailey Conway angle
witz is the executive producer while
executive producer roles can vary in how
involved they are she's essentially the
person who funds the movie so she may
not be the definitive Source on lore
related